[Música]
de acuerdo con las encuestas de salida
Benjamín netanyahu ex Primer Ministro y
líder de la oposición en Israel podría
volver al poder si su partido gana las
elecciones parlamentarias en ese país
gracias En buena parte a quienes su
partido licut se presentaron a estos
comicios con varios partidos aliados
algunos partidos religiosos y otros de
Ultra derecha lo que no queda del todo
claro es si sale electo podrá conformar
Un gobierno repasemos algunos datos
básicos de la situación allí Benjamín
netanyahu es el hidropositor también es
el líder del partido licut ha sido
Primer Ministro en reiteradas ocasiones
la primera vez fue entre 1996 y 1999 es
quien más años ha ejercido ese Cargo en
Israel 12 años consecutivos 15 años en
total ahí ven ustedes en la pantalla las
referencias de las diferentes periodos
como Primer Ministro de Israel algunos
datos básicos de su Estilo de gobierno
muy por encima porque vamos a
profundizar de esto en el programa es
defensor del Libre Mercado ha reducido
los impuestos en algunos momentos de su
gobierno y ha reducido también los
impuestos a los ingresos durante su
gobierno Israel experimentó una especie
de milagro económico gracias a sus
medidas consideradas como de corte
capitalismo popular así lo llaman
algunos analistas apoya también la
libertad y los derechos de la comunidad
lgbti de ahí que Israel sea uno de los
países más abiertos en este tema a nivel
mundial y esto es muy significativo
porque este país está ubicado en pleno
medio oriente rodeado de países
musulmanes pero ya veremos este tema
Cómo se va a desarrollar si vuelve al
gobierno por esta alianza que tiene con
los partidos religiosos un poco más
conservadores netan Yahoo también se
opuso a los acuerdos de oslo esta serie
de acuerdos que fueron firmados entre el
entonces gobierno de Israel y la
organización para la liberación de
Palestina unos acuerdos que buscaban dar
una solución definitiva para ese
conflicto palestinos e israelíes también
fue acusado de varios casos de
corrupción
netanyahu es el único Primer Ministro de
Israel que ha sido imputado durante su
mandato por casos de fraude y abuso en
los casos mil y 2000 y por favor no si
fraude en el llamado caso 4000 así las
cosas Entonces qué significaría el
regreso de netallao y del licut a la
escena política de Israel que escenario
se abre entonces para una posible paz
con los palestinos el propio netan Yahoo
ha advertido que establecerá un gobierno
nacionalista esto que características
entonces va a tener dada la coyuntura
que está viviendo el país en estos
momentos alcanzará los 61 diputados para
formar el gobierno saldrá Israel de esta
crisis política todas estas preguntas
que son estas y muchas más las vamos a
responder aquí en el debate de France 24
y para analizar este tema hemos invitado
a Eduardo conn Él es director de
beneybrid para América Latina también es
experto en diplomacia israelí y
relaciones interna Cuál es él se
encuentra en la ciudad de Montevideo en
la capital de la República Oriental del
Uruguay y desde Jerusalén en Israel se
encuentra Gabriel ventas gal él es
analista político especialista en temas
de medio oriente ustedes nuestros
televidentes también Pueden seguir
siendo parte de este debate Pueden
seguir todos los comentarios de nuestros
analistas y comentar sobre lo que ellos
dicen dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram ustedes ya lo saben no se
encuentran en todas las redes sociales
como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
junto todo pegado no se olviden también
que todos los contenidos del programa
están también disponibles En plataformas
en diferentes plataformas de podcast
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo Entonces por Eduardo en la
ciudad de Montevideo dándole la
bienvenida a Eduardo Muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa Y
pregunta para el inicio del debate y del
Análisis Qué significa entonces este
eventual regreso de Benjamín netanyahu a
la política de Israel y para esa
conformación del gobierno israelí
gracias por la invitación un gusto estar
con ustedes Bueno si se confirma
efectivamente cuando se haga el conteo
la victoria de netaniau y la alianza con
los partidos que esta vez lo apoyarán
para una coalición no parece tener los
61 votos que usted mencionó sino más
tener hasta 64 o 65 eso es un cambio
sustancial de los últimos años en que no
se lograba una mayoría sólida Y eso
lógicamente no le hace bien al país para
no para desarrollarse porque Israel está
desarrollandose en forma vertiginosa
pero sí para establecer una un programa
de gobierno por lo menos en cuatro años
si hay en un año y medio cuatro o cinco
elecciones porque no hay mayorías
parlamentarias esto le da una solidez
diferente a cualquier gobierno que venga
y eso es lo que ha manifestado la
evidentemente la población israelí
votando de esta manera evidentemente va
Hay mucha hay mucho para contestar y
mucho rato para hablar que no es el caso
en televisión pero
significa también para el mundo o sea
para el mundo occidental para el medio
oriente un cambio porque se conoce usted
mismo ha dicho algunas características
se conoce de como gobierno netaniado se
conoce sus opiniones en política
exterior pero en la novedad es Cómo
lograr a conformar su gobierno y
mantener ese tipo de opiniones en
política exterior donde en general ha
tratado de cómo lo hago es Israel de
llevarse en la mejor forma posible y
tener relaciones en todos los
continentes y con todos los países por
último usted mencionó al principio
el tema de Usted dijo que va a haber
Alianza con la Ultra derecha le pido
disculpas pero la definición de
ultraderecha a nosotros por lo menos los
judíos no suena algo dictatorial
extremista y nos hace recordar épocas
tenebrosas de los años 30 que sean de
derecha y conservadores perfectos pero
ultraderecha significa otra cosa y por
más conservador que sean los partidos en
Israel todos acuerdan
votaciones democráticas y todos
intervienen en la democracia con las
leyes de la Democracia importante esa
aclaración y Punto de partida de Eduardo
con en la ciudad de Montevideo pasó a
preguntarle entonces a Gabriel su
opinión lo que significa este eventual
regreso cuando sean confirmados por
parte de la autoridad electoral israelí
Este triunfo pero a Boca de urna como lo
decía al inicio del programa Tal parece
que el licut lidera regresa con esta
coalición de gobierno
Sí es bastante los resultados han sido
bastante contundentes
vinagretaniau va a ser el próximo Primer
Ministro de Israel y la gran pregunta no
es si él va a ser sino con quién porque
la naturaleza de las relaciones que
tiene este momento internas en detaneado
nos indica que lo lógico sería que se
incline hacia la derecha y se incline
hacia los partidos religiosos que son
Juntos sumarían por lo menos 65 escaños
o 64 más o menos por ese número le tenía
un no suele gobernar de esa manera a él
le gusta tener aliados a la izquierda él
también o sea que él situarse en el
medio para tener más margen de maniobra
por lo tanto La pregunta es si va a
lograr convencer algún partido de centro
de unirse a su coalición por ejemplo el
partido de benigans Y de esa forma
tendría
aliados a la izquierda aliados a la
derecha y aliados a través de los
partidos ortodoxos entonces de acuerdo a
ese escenario que usted describe Gabriel
podría entonces haber una negociación
con algún partido de derecha con el
escenario político como está el país con
esta crisis que lleva presentando desde
hace cuatro años estará fácil esa
negociación con el centro y con esos
partidos de un espectro un poco más
alejado del de El liquid
técnicamente sería de la siguiente forma
el partido de derecha ese llamado el
cristianismo religioso no está
conformado por un solo partido de hecho
son tres entonces netaniao y el estadio
podría negociar con parte de él Porque
además cuando termina las elecciones
cada uno se separa de esos partidos O
sea que perfectamente podría introducir
algunos y a otros no De qué depende de
que pueda hacer esto y bueno depende de
que algún partido de Centro esté
dispuesto a entrar una coalición con
letanía o cuando el mapa político del
país se ha de venir se ha dividido no de
forma ideológica sino de forma
irracional en donde se divide los votos
por los que están a favor de letania u y
los que están en contra detallado
creando una situación de una brecha
parecida a lo que vimos en Argentina con
Cristina kirchner parecía lo que vimos
en Brasil con bolsonaro y parecía lo que
vimos en Estados Unidos con Donald Trump
la gente ha dejado de votar por lo que
cree que es correcto sino que se ha
transformado en
de alguna manera y internet
le doy ahora la palabra a Eduardo en la
ciudad de Montevideo teniendo entonces
un poco más claro tratando de entender
esta política israelí desde el lado
latinoamericano Eduardo
entendiendo entonces que licut llega
acompañado de estos partidos religiosos
de estos partidos de derecha como usted
muy bien lo ha aclarado en términos
prácticos en el día a día esta coalición
del gobierno
sin duda alguna Será muy distinto a los
gobiernos que ha tenido donde tan Yahoo
en el pasado cómo sería entonces en
términos prácticos ese rumbo que podría
tener
hay un tema que no es diferente con
ningún gobierno en Israel en toda su
historia y es el tema de la seguridad
nacional y eso el país lo sabe los
ciudadanos lo saben y los gobiernos
también lo saben porque Lamentablemente
después de 70 años
Israel sigue amenazada existencialmente
Incluso se le amenaza en los propios
foros de Naciones Unidas inca Naciones
Unidas se le mueva un pelo de todo por
lo tanto el tema de seguridad nacional
que no es menor porque es un gasto muy
importante del presupuesto pero el tema
de seguridad es un tema en que podrá
haber matices pero solo matices pero eso
es un tema en común en los temas
sociales políticos económicos Bueno
políticamente lo ha dicho Gabriel muy
claro el tema de del hoy ser un poco
hincha de fútbol eso en general no le
hacen ni bien ni mal a la democracia la
de forma entonces lo que va a tener que
buscar netaniado es que justamente con
sus políticas sociales y con sus
políticas
económicas lograr acuerdos importantes
para que Israel siga desarrollándose
como se está desarrollando hoy en día
que está en una posición económica
envidiable Viene un proceso de es una
nación startup tiene un proceso altísimo
de startup en este momento con ingresos
muy grandes y eso hay que mantenerlo Por
más que él ha dicho que va evidentemente
apoyar con con gasto público
determinadas reformas de la educación
probablemente el parlamento controle eso
porque en un momento cuando un país está
bien económicamente Ni más ni menos que
pospandemia y muy cerca de una guerra
como la que hay en Europa la economía
debe ser cuidada muy especialmente
Israel está en una situación muy
ventajosa desde ese punto de vista En
comparación con lo que puede estar
Europa y otras partes del mundo Así que
lo que creemos es que va a tener que
hacer equilibrios y desde el punto de
vista reitero de la seguridad nacional
no hay discusiones en lo esencial por
razones existenciales claro tan simple
como eso es un tema transversal para el
gobierno que llegue de turno a Israel es
un tema de suma importancia dado el
contexto que tiene alrededor Gabriel su
opinión sobre cómo esto en la práctica
cómo se verá reflejada esta negociación
esta posible coalición que temas así
como Eduardo destacaba los ve usted más
sobre la mesa
bueno en la líneas generales coincido
con el gran maestro que tengo al lado
mío Eduardo con
lo que podemos señalar como algunas
diferencias con el gobierno anterior Por
más que el gobierno anterior ha durado
solamente un año en el poder es que
netaniao viene con un bagaje y un
pedigrí que lapiz no tenía si tú por
ejemplo fueses el ayatola Ali jameney y
intentas hacer algún tipo de movimiento
nuclear en contra Israel
Creo yo que temerías más si enfrente
tuyo está netaneado que si está la vida
o sea netaniao es visto como un Primer
Ministro con más experiencia con más
contundencia y con más influencia
política a nivel mundial eso por un lado
lo que te digo a nivel económico interno
es que netaniau es visto como alguien
que realmente sabe profundamente temas
económicos y que ha logrado que un
israelí promedio hoy reciba de sueldos
anuales 55 mil dólares
anuales y que la marca Israel en sus
inventos a nivel general se destaca en
el mundo O sea yo creo que hay dos cosas
para señalar
bueno perdemos la conexión con Gabriel
en Jerusalén vamos a retomarlo ustedes
saben estos temas técnicos pasan cuando
estamos en vivo pero seguimos conectados
con Eduardo en la ciudad de Montevideo
Ah bueno no me confirman que Gabriel ya
está otra vez con nosotros Gabriel puede
terminar retomé un poco lo que estaba
diciendo al final que se nos cortó la
señal por favor
no Simplemente que teníamos transmite
más experiencia y por lo tanto esa es
una ventaja que quizás puede llegar a
tener en comparación con el gobierno
anterior y lo segundo es que los
mercados confían más en un Primer
Ministro con la experiencia económica
que ha tenido no tenía agua en el pasado
Gabriel continuó con usted para hacerle
una pregunta a usted se encuentra Jenny
Israel está en el día a día de de este
país en qué momento Benjamín netanjado
se convirtió en una figura de suma
importancia en el escenario político de
este país por eso 15 años al frente de
del gobierno como Primer Ministro doce
años de ellos de forma consecutiva Eso
habla mucho del liderazgo que él tiene
en el país cuáles fueron esos puntos
claves que lo catapultaron como un líder
y como un Primer Ministro de importancia
para la vida política
primero cuando durante años netaniau
decía no hace falta firmar una paz con
los palestinos para lograr que el mundo
árabe también
siente y se siente contigo a firmar un
acuerdo de paz
sino que nadie le creía a él que era
posible
adelante
al final se terminó confirmando como que
era algo real netania logró Los acuerdos
de Abraham que fueron obra de su
perspectiva
lo segundo
Gabriel vamos a revisar su conexión de
internet porque se nos está cortando es
importante el punto que usted está
abordando en este momento le voy a dar
la palabra Eduardo para que opine sobre
este tema mientras el equipo técnico
trata de mejorar la señal con usted
Eduardo retomemos entonces la pregunta
sobre este personaje importante para la
vida política de Israel desde su punto
de vista desde su análisis que lo llevó
a convertirse en esta figura central
hoy en día he tomado de perspectiva
Benjamín etania tiene 50 años de vida
entre diplomática académica y política y
además de sus casi dos décadas entre una
y otra primera de siendo Primer Ministro
al frente del país O sea no sólo
experiencia sino hay una historia y su
historia es de primer nivel y por eso
como decía Gabriel está claro de que
evidentemente lo vendes del exterior que
si tienen que estar discutiendo
cualquier este tipo de tema con un
Primer Ministro como netania o están
discutiendo con alguien con mucha
experiencia y con muchos éxitos en su
experiencia Los acuerdos de Abraham que
estaba diciendo Gabriel son contundentes
o sea el mundo no creía y sigue sigue
gran parte del mundo no creyendo y sin
embargo se van agregando países porque
no sólo los acuerdos de Abraham trajeron
la unión económica social incluso
cultural con emiratos árabes con Uruguay
con perdón con bagreen sino que además
han agregado sin estar quizás firmando
acuerdos especiales una rigorización con
Marruecos también se ha agregado Sudán
se ha agregado una renovación diferente
de relacionamiento con Turquía se han
firmado un acuerdo muy importante
económico con Líbano a la semana pasada
a pesar de que las relaciones
diplomáticas no están ni hablar lo que
ya existe con Egipto y con Jordania
Entonces ese mapa ese mapa construido
durante la vida del liderazgo de
Benjamín etaniau un poco antes este con
el tema de Egipto de Jordania pero con
netañón se construyó todo este mapa que
hay hoy en día y eso cambia radicalmente
las relaciones en medio oriente de los
países de medio oriente y
fundamentalmente de aquellos países que
todavía insisten de que tienen que
destruir a Israel y sacarlo del mapa y
echarlo al mar eso hoy no funciona en la
liga árabe porque hay muchos países que
ya tienen acuerdos Y funciona el acuerdo
especialmente en el campo económico y
social es muy elevado el nivel de
comercios bilaterales y multilaterales
porque ya han habido conferencias entre
todos los países y eso pienso que va a
marcar este periodo este nuevo periodo
del Primer Ministro este en estanismos
llegado a formar gobierno lo va a marcar
muy claramente muy claramente Eduardo
hemos hablado del bagaje que tiene del
linaje político que tiene de la
contundencia a la hora de tomar deci
opciones hay diferentes sectores
políticos y sociales de Israel que
discrepan con algunas de las decisiones
y políticas de netallao y reconocen o no
algunos puntos de su gobierno a lo largo
de estos 15 años sin embargo bueno no
estaríamos en este programa si no fuera
sorpresivo su regreso a la escena
política porque está siendo juzgado por
cargos de corrupción que él mismo niega
Cómo se puede entender eso
creo que eso se entiende solamente en
democracia eso no se puede entender en
países que no son democráticos o sea en
este momento sí es cierto hay juicios
pendientes pero como existe en todo el
mundo donde hay democracias y existe el
estado de derecho nadie es culpable
hasta que se lo demuestre o sea en el
camino en el camino está pendiente y eso
evidentemente lo demuestra la votaciones
No sólo esta quizás las anteriores
también no es tan sorpresivo que haya
ganado las elecciones Israel venía con
gobiernos con buenas acciones
manteniendo Los acuerdos de Abraham el
gobierno de lapiz como mencionó Gabriel
Pero hay una realidad el país decidió
que vuelva un líder reconocido un líder
que que el país lo reconoce como
conductor claro el país bueno esperará
la decisión judicial o la decisión
judicial llegará o no llegará en los
tiempos que corresponden pero el
evidentemente no lo está viendo como
esos análisis que suelen ser recurrentes
especialmente en determinadas prensas
internacionales que hacen hincapié en
eso Y por supuesto algunos Países Árabes
que todavía no tienen relaciones con
Israel pero lo concreto es que ellos
vieron un líder político que se presentó
a las elecciones el tema judicial tiene
que resolver la justicia por lo tanto
una independencia de instituciones
claramente haya logrado que haya logrado
vencer en las elecciones cuando Israel
estaba buscando de una buena vez Un
gobierno por cuatro años y medio también
es muy eficiente Gabriel que según las
cifras oficiales y esto teniendo en
cuenta que todavía el conteo de votos el
recuento de votos continúa durante estos
comicios Israel presentó la
participación más altas en unas
elecciones parlamentarias desde 1999 qué
lectura se puede hacer sobre esto
la gente está buscando definir
necesita un gobierno de cuatro años
porque si no hay gobierno no hay
presupuesto Y si no hay presupuesto no
se establece las prioridades nacionales
ante tanto cansanciosa recurre y esto es
importante a una figura política que
tiene una cualidad que es muy apreciada
por los israelíes Robert el famoso
politólogo decía que tú tienes autoridad
en sociedades conservadoras y no muy
desarrolladas o no muy democráticas si
tienen es el sustento de la tradición o
de la Ley Sin embargo en el estado de
Israel y en otros países Realmente
desarrollados el sustento de un buen
líder se basa en Su carisma y en su
conocimiento y netanía un posee mucho
carisma y también un conocimiento
acumulado que ha logrado varios de los
hits ítems que hemos señalado antes como
los acuerdos de Abraham como la
superación económica del estado de
Israel
por ejemplo la situación en donde Isabel
es una potencia militar que es apreciada
en el medio oriente y que ayuda a sus
hermanos sunitas a parar y detener la
amenaza iraní que es común para todos
pasó a darle la palabra a Eduardo lo
mencionamos una necesidad de destrabar
esta crisis política quinta selecciones
legislativas en menos de cuatro años
esta alta participación pues lo que uno
puede ver ahí de lectura es que tampoco
hay un desgaste en el electorado la
gente todavía participa y quiere ser
partícipe de este proceso electoral pero
que hay de la democracia y que hay de de
ese escenario en el que se encuentra el
país como Israel llegó a esta gran
división a esta polarización que en la
que se encuentra que ha tenido que
realizar cinco elecciones en cuatro años
cuando claramente lo que uno puede ver
desde Israel Es que la unidad es lo que
ha sostenido a este país por su propia
necesidad de existencia
bueno En primer término Insisto Hay un
tema que no se discute la seguridad
nacional eso es transversal en segundo
término
la polarización Bueno es un tema que
estamos viendo no solo en Israel estamos
viendo en la mayoría de las democracias
hay polarizaciones importantes es
consecuencia de la pandemia que trajo
una crisis económica social y en algunos
casos política enorme y que no se
esperaba y que fue un golpe repentino
que no se pudo preparar y fue muy
difícil enfrentarlo puede ser que además
lo agrava en el caso europeo y extendido
ni que hablar al Medio Oriente la
invasión rusa a Ucrania hace ocho meses
sin duda también pero las polarizaciones
o fundamentalmente en estos últimos tres
años no solo en el último año y medio en
estos últimos tres años en el mundo y en
las democracias han tenido dos
características que quiero señalar una
las Muchas gracias no dejaron de ser
democracias no sé o sea se sigue votando
en libertad que es el caso de Israel Y
en segundo término evidentemente ante el
golpe de la pandemia ante esa
paralización brutal en el primer año en
casi todo el mundo en las tragedias
etcétera que trajo se buscaron la gente
fue buscando soluciones Quizás hasta
mágicas o repentinas Y eso no hay
entonces evidentemente eso llegó a
polarizaciones no extraña que le haya
pasado Israel pero también esa segunda
cosa que quiero decir la demostración de
que la situación económica actual de
Israel en comparación a otras
democracias y la situación de que es la
mayor participación en una votación que
no es obligatoria en prácticamente los
últimos 30 o 35 años
demuestra que Israel se recuperó más
rápido y por eso tiene una democracia
más sólida
importante ese punto Eduardo en la
ciudad de Montevideo Gabriel escalemos
esto un poco al escenario internacional
ya que Eduardo toca estas diferentes
aristas de la coyuntura internacional
este regreso de licut un gobierno de
derecho a una gran coalición que Podría
empezar a gobernar en Israel que impacto
Podría tener en el escenario
internacional Israel tiene una relación
cercana con Ucrania también con Rusia
pero Rusia ha desarrollado en los
últimos meses o por lo menos ha
estrechado lazos con Irán que es un país
enemigo de Israel histórico pero también
hay evolución con Turquía los menciono a
todos estos países porque hay algo en
común y es el conflicto Precisamente en
el este de Ucrania y también la relación
que puede haber con Estados Unidos ya a
lo largo de estos años pues netanyahu ha
tenido una estrecha relación con Estados
Unidos pero pero cómo cambiaría entonces
allí el escenario lo preguntó Porque
Israel puede ser un país pequeño en
extensión pero importante en decisión
sí totalmente depende más que nada de lo
que decía Estados Unidos al ser verdad
porque el tema central para la
preocupación de Israel es la capacidad
nuclear iraní si Vayven copia los
patrones de conducta de un primer de un
presidente perdón como Barack oseno
Obama que fue prácticamente despreciado
en el medio oriente no era querido en
absoluto y era tratado como una persona
inocente Bueno si vayden va a copiar el
patrón de conducta de Barack Obama de
acercarse a Irán e intentar llegar a un
acuerdo cuando todo el mundo sabe que
Irán le va a mentir a Estados Unidos eso
es algo que netanía aún no va a aceptar
y va a enfrentar a bailén como lo hizo
ya con Obama con la diferencia que
vaiden no es Obama va a identificar
postura mucho más realista con respecto
a lo que Irán está buscando entonces con
respecto a byden yo no creo que sea una
relación nueva sino que baile nião se
conocen hace décadas
Entonces no creo que sea lo mismo pero
depende de Estados Unidos y su
perspectiva con respecto irán con
respecto a Rusia durante muchos años
Isabel ha mantenido una buena relación
con ambos países con Ucrania y con Rusia
Especialmente con Rusia porque Rusia es
el dueño de Siria y en Siria se instalan
todo el tiempo fuerzas iraníes y dejéis
balá para abrir otro frente aatat contra
Israel y es por eso que Israel ataca en
suelo sirio con el visto bueno de Rusia
cuando viene Ucrania y le pide Israel
necesitamos armas indispensables que
ustedes tienen y que no tiene nadie más
en el mundo como drones de ataque o como
el sistema antimisilístico cúpula de
hierro Israel tiene un dilema porque por
un lado le gustaría ayudar a Ucrania por
otro lado necesita seguir protegiendo a
sus ciudadanos de unirán instalado en
Siria ese dilema netanía Hugo lo va a
manejar con mayor experiencia eso es de
esperar porque ya lo ha hecho durante
años y Eduardo en ese escenario
internacional Vámonos a un conflicto un
poco más pequeño pero que también es muy
importante es el conflicto en el cáucaso
a Israel lo han señalado mucho por estar
colaborando con las fuerzas de
azerbaiyán por venderle drones por este
estrechamiento en las relaciones
diplomáticas Esto es estratégico para
mantener un poco más vigilado a Irán
porque claramente estos drones israelíes
y turcos están siendo utilizados para
bombardear algunos algunas posiciones en
Armenia y en la región de nagorno
caravag y pues bueno ya hemos tratado
varias veces el tema del conflicto allí
en en
a nivel internacional Pero cómo entender
esa posición de Israel apoyar a
azerbaiyán en este caso por un tema
comercial o cómo se puede entender
y doloroso es doloroso hablar del tema
pero hay una expresión en derecho
público en derecho internacional que es
la razón de estado y la razón de estado
es la razón de vivir de cada estado y
evidentemente lo explicó Gabriel muy
bien con el otro conflicto con las otras
posibilidades de relaciones
Irán No no es solo enemigo de Israel no
no no el gobierno de Irán instalado de
los ayatolas desde que se instaló este
gobierno no no los anteriores lo único
que hace prácticamente todos los días si
pudiera pero por lo menos con mucha
frecuencia es decir que quiere terminar
con la existencia del Estado judío de
Israel o sea quiere exterminar a Israel
y borrarlo del mapa y no lo dice con
eufemismos y no lo dice con vueltas
entonces Israel tiene un tema
existencial Porque además Irán está
haciendo una carrera armamentista
nuclear entonces
evidentemente hay razones de estado que
obligan a un estado pequeño como Israel
que es muy pequeño evidentemente
físicamente me refiero a defenderse del
enemigo que lo quiere destruir y eso
hace que evidentemente los distintos
gobiernos no solo el gobierno que va a
venir ahora de netania o los anteriores
de netaniaus tengan que tomar decisiones
que evidentemente son dolorosas y además
a la vista pública pueden parecer
chocantes como usted mismo lo dice y es
en el caso del conflicto entre
azerbaiyán y Armenia en el tema de las
relaciones con Turquía porque el
gobierno de Israel sabe perfectamente
Cómo se juegan los derechos humanos en
Turquía y se juegan muy mal Claro pero
está el problema existencial como dijo
Gabriel también un Primer Ministro como
netaniado con mucha experiencia y
conociendo muy bien a quienes hoy el
primer el presidente perdón de Turquía y
que a cómo son y además conociendo a
gobernantes de la región Probablemente
lo maneje diferente a como se ha podido
manejar ahora simplemente por ese
conocimiento de las cosas de las
personas y de saber que tiene que hacer
un equilibrio que es muy difícil porque
la razón de estado siempre es muy
difícil de equilibrar entrar la razón de
la existencia y la razón de la defensa
de las causas Más democráticas o más
justas que puedan parecerle al resto del
mundo Eduardo Sí ahí queda uno un poco
confundido porque Entonces estaría
defendiendo esta relación con bakú
Acosta de la muerte de armenios y de
ciudadanos de nagorno caravag y ellos
que defienden la existencia de Israel
estarían también aquí involucrados en la
desaparición de la región de astas que
es una República no reconocida a nivel
internacional y tampoco entiende uno esa
relación con Turquía teniendo ese pasado
en común del genocidio Turco sobre los
armenios y el pasado que tiene Israel
ahí hay unas hay una especie de doble
rasero o cómo lo podemos Llamar Gabriel
para entender esas decisiones que tome
Israel que uno tal vez no queda muy
claro que rumbo puede tomar el próximo
gobierno en cuanto a esos temas
es que en ambos puntos tengo que hacer
la aclaración primero el hecho que hay
varios problemas con lo que me acabas de
preguntar eh lo primero
durante la Primera Guerra Mundial fue un
asesinados cristianos por el hecho de
ser cristianos la mayoría de ellos En
armenios pero también fueron asesinados
cristianos griegos pero fueron asociados
por ser cristianos y fueron asesinados a
manos de musulmanes
el hecho de que hayamos tenido una
pasado como un judío así armenios no
significa que hoy Turquía que asesinó a
aquellos armenios hoy en día no haya
tenido hace pocos meses pasados de apoyo
a grupos terroristas muy problemáticos
como el ihh ligado al caída o a jamás O
sea la sede de planificación atentados
que dada en Turquía hasta hace poco
porque erdogan era quien lo apoyaba O
sea que Israel puede perfectamente ahora
mejorar sus relaciones con erdogan pero
lo mira con muchísimas sospecha y
segundo azerbaiyán es un Aliado de
Israel porque azerbaiyán ha permitido
durante años que se vigile desde adentro
lo que ocurre en Irán
azerbaiyán es un Aliado geopolítico de
Israel muy serio Porque además dentro de
Irán existe azerbaiyán hay una provincia
que ha sido conquistada por los persas y
que los Aceros quieren conseguirla de
vuelta para su país por lo tanto no es
solamente es una cuestión también
estrategia geopolítica azerbaiyán ha
dado mucho a la relación con Israel y ha
facilitado mucho que Israel actúe de
forma muy contundente contra Irán cuando
lo ha querido y lo podemos ver en las
noticias cuando se puso Israel de haber
atacado a Irán de distintas formas por
ejemplo a través de ir selectivamente
trabajando con los científicos que están
desarrollando armas nucleares Sí en
ciertas denuncias que hace y dan de
sabotajes en sus plantas y en sus
laboratorios donde están desarrollando
su su programa nuclear me quedan ya
pocos minutos para terminar el programa
Este es un tema muy interesante pero
claramente entender la política de
israelí en 35 minutos no no nos
alcanzará el tiempo pero vamos a llegar
a las conclusiones voy a darle un poco
más de tiempo a lo normal porque sé que
hay muchos temas para abordar en ellas
entonces Eduardo al lado y la palabra
conclusión que sigue entonces para
Israel un nuevo gobierno se acaba esta
crisis política lo lidera en netallao el
licut y la coalición Y qué futuro
Entonces lo espera para este país
Bueno si se confirma y se conforma una
mayoría Como dijo Gabriel entre 64 y 65
escaños va a haber un gobierno sólido
con discrepancias como ha habido siempre
en democracia porque va a haber
oposición y así funciona la democracia
pero Israel insisto está en una
situación hoy económica favorable nada
extraordinario venimos de pandemia y de
guerra pero está en una situación
favorable el manejo de netaniado de la
economía en todos sus gobiernos
anteriores hace pensar que va a lograr
con el ministro de finanzas que sea y
con las carteras que sean mantener ese
el establecimiento de esa economía
fuerte porque es lo que le sirve a
Israel probablemente pueda haber
discusiones a nivel social o educativo
por temas ideológicos internos que
siempre hay no solo en las democracias
sino en este caso particular en Israel
Este pero eso es habitual y netaniado ha
sabido manejarlos muy bien Eduardo
justamente este juntándose con
movimientos más de centro y tratando de
balancear en el tema social interno y
desde el punto de vista de internacional
y de relacionamiento
para darle la palabra Gabriel termino y
desde el punto de vista internacional
concuerdo totalmente con Gabriel la
palabra primero la va a tener Estados
Unidos es lo que siente Israel y después
vendrá lo demás con Europa y los otros
países ya lo veremos entonces Eduardo
Gabriel su conclusión para el cierre
ahora el presidente va a citar a todos
los líderes los partidos políticos y
probablemente ni teníamos reciba durante
28 Días el derecho de formar gobierno
esperamos Un gobierno que trate con
temas de la crisis mundial económica y
temas judiciales internos que tiene
problemas Israel a la espera de lo que
ocurra con Irán sabes qué
lo más importante se ha formado Un
gobierno que esperemos dure algo de
tiempo porque simplemente ya nos hemos
cansado de ir a elecciones y de
elecciones una vez cada tanto es
divertido y la elecciones cinco veces en
tres años parece Ya traumático pues a
Gabriel y Eduardo panel de primerísimo
nivel les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros hoy en el programa haber hecho
este análisis tratar de entender la
política Israel y lo que se viene para
este país después de las elecciones
parlamentarias vamos a ver entonces en
qué termina esta historia ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con France
[Música]